hi in this video I would talk about my
scania gravis now my ste mia means
related to muscle and gravis means grave
so it's something a disease related to
the muscle so my senior gravis is an
autoimmune disorder where our own immune
system which works like the defense
system of a country is against our own
body which could be dangerous right
the initial symptoms of my stinger
gravis includes drooping eyelids severe
muscle pain and in the long run it could
cause muscular atrophy and imagine if
the muscles which are associated with
breathing and it's get affected by
myasthenia gravis or weakened by
myasthenia gravis or there is a atrophy
in those muscles then it could be
life-threatening now let's just take a
look at the neuromuscular Junction which
is a key center of incidence in case of
my senior gravis in order to understand
the biology behind the disease so here
is a biceps if we zoom in we would see
there is neuromuscular junction the
junction between nerve and the muscle
cells inside the muscle cells there are
sarcomeres we should be contracting or
expanding when a stimulus comes from the
north when we want to move the muscle
now when we want to move the muscle the
nerves are firing and as a result there
are acetylcholine receptors on the
muscle which is allowing cationic influx
inside the muscle and that allows the
sarcomeres to shorten now whenever our
nerve impulse is
reaching the terminal it would create a
postsynaptic potential which would allow
calcium influx from the sarcoplasmic
reticulum and that increased calcium
would allow to slide the actin and
myosin on one top of another and thereby
the muscle is getting contracted now
let's just look at a closer view to a
one neuromuscular Junction so here in
the blue is the neuron and the orange is
the muscle as at the North Terminal
acetylcholine is secreted and the
acetylcholine binds to acetylcholine
receptors the nicotinic acetylcholine
receptors here which are nothing but
cation channels which allow cationic
influx into the muscle that generates
the postsynaptic potential in the muscle
and gives the muscle the energy or the
signal to contract what happens in
myasthenia gravis is there are specific
subtype of B cells which are
differentiating into antibody producing
plasma cells and these antibodies are
specific to the acetylcholine receptor
now when there is too much of acetyl
anti acetylcholine receptor antibodies
in our body
these acetylcholine receptor antibodies
can bind to the acetylcholine receptors
which kind of inhibits or prevents the
normal ligand of this receptor that
means the acetylcholine to bind as a
result cationic interlocks cannot happen
and proper muscular contraction cannot
happen as a result the person would feel
hard to perform a task or a repetitive
tasks like cooking like writing etcetera
now not only it would the myasthenia
gravis produce Auto antibody against the
acetylcholine receptor but at the same
time it pretty it can fix complement
cascade the complement proteins can bind
on top of antibody and allow membrane
attack complex and this membrane attack
complex are generally meant to kill
bacteria or pathogens which are coming
which are considered as a pathogen but
this system can be utilized against its
own
body and to create a membrane attack
complex and that thereby damaging the
nerve terminals and the muscles now some
of these complement proteins which could
be fixed by these autoimmune antibodies
can also give rise to some cleaved
component component of the complement
pathway which are put into an aflatoxin
meaning they can allow mobilization of
specific monocytes into the tissue space
where they would be differentiated into
macrophages and these macrophages can
act upon into the muscle and these
macrophages would secrete inflammatory
cytokines like il-1 il-6 TNF alpha etc
which would overall increase the
inflammation in the local site of the
neuromuscular Junction and that thereby
we feed the mycenaean Kravis patient
feel a lot of pain
now this overall inflammation and pain
makes the disease even worse the
potential treatment options include
acetylcholine esterase
in a moment we would look how this can
work at a biological level other than
that suppressing the immune system is
one option but not a fruitful one
because once you suppress the immune
system then you are susceptible to more
bacterial and viral infections empty
inflammatory drugs such as
corticosteroids can give a temporary
relief because it can reduce the
inflammation and at the chronic
situation where the situation is too bad
then time'll remove thymus removal could
be one option but this is not good since
you know that thymus is the training
school for t-cell and once you remove
the thymus there would be very less
amount of t-cells from in your body so
your and your immune system would be
extremely weak so let's just take a
moment to watch how acetylcholine
esterase could be a proper treatment
option for my senior graphs we know that
normally the cholinergic system the
acetylcholine is released at the North
terminals where after a point of time
the acetylcholine esterase
Cleaves the acetyl
thereby it stops the response so the
muscle cannot contract for in less time
right so there's the the signal to be
switched on and switched off and the
switching off is basically done by
acetylcholine esterase now what happens
in case of my senior gravis is you have
to kind of thing competing for the same
as cell column receptor one is the
acetylcholine receptor antibody and
second is the acetylcholine itself their
computation they are competing to bind
to the acetylcholine receptor now if you
plug the acetylcholine esterase then
what happens the acetylcholine won't be
degraded in the synaptic cleft that
increases the availability of
acetylcholine in the synaptic cleft once
estelle choline is abundant in the
synaptic cleft then the probability that
acetylcholine would bind and beat the
autoimmune antibody is more and as a
result proper calcium influx could
happen and the muscle neuromuscular
Junction could function properly and
person person can move their muscles
properly so this is how acetylcholine
esterase could be a proper treatment for
myasthenia gravis if you like my
explanations and like my video give it a
quick thumbs up don't forget to Like
share and subscribe and also let me know
in comments how do you like my videos
thank you